salamualikum' guys you know know the
beautiful thing that when Liam Neeson
when he was in Turkey the famous actor
the call to prayer starts at 5 a.m.
every morning so when you have your
alarm clock set for 6 a.m. it's the
first week that was a bit annoying do
you get used to it
but by the second week it just gets into
your soul in the most magnificent way
cool at first because it was odd to him
he was hearing this began to call to
prayer but then it has such a great
effect on him
and that's one of the beautiful things
you're here in Bosnian you got to get to
hear this come to prayer come to prayer
come to success come to success it's
beautiful really touches my heart it
just gets into your soul in the most
magnificent and for the night yet
Muslims who who are getting a chance to
hear this it's it's a call to to leave
everything of this world and go and
thank the one who created you your
Creator
the worship of him alone not his
creation
did you hear that isn't that beautiful
who'll give you life will give you deaf
you have to leave this transitory life
behind pretty soon so you appreciate
it's got what kind of relationship is
when you just keep taking and taking but
you're not giving me not even a thanks
come on so else we're gonna do
we're gonna get thanks and you are the
beautiful event here in must are in
Bosnia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]